[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias por esa presentación
por estar ustedes aquí y por todas las
personas que colaboran con esta
maravillosa experiencia virtual de una
universidad gratuita para el universo
va a agregar algo a esta presentación
que casi nunca lo comparto con las
personas pero al año y medio volver a mi
tierra medellín después de estar tanto
tiempo por fuera lo quiero hacer con
ustedes
y tiene mucho que ver con lo que
comparten entienden colombia y el mundo
tantas personas como las que hemos visto
esta tarde aquí y es la fuerza de la
mente del corazón de poner el alma de
liberar de no rendirte y eso lo quiero
agradecer a fidel ante de ustedes
hablando del sendero del espíritu un
camino que recorren las personas en
religión o sin ella dándole gracias a mi
padre y a mi madre porque es muy extraño
amigas y amigos que yo ahora es center y
haya estado en tantos escenarios de
américa latina y de otras partes y que
no sea un conferencista y que hable en
la televisión y que haya estado en la
radio cuando gonzalo gallo en el barrio
las palmas de medellín
a tres cuadras del cementerio ya no se
me anterior ahora parque de san lorenzo
casi no aprende a hablar casi no suelta
la lengua como diríamos el lenguaje
nuestro mi mamá muy preocupada yo
también porque al frente de mi casa
parqueaban un carro que transportaba
carne y yo miraba el carro y le decía a
los amiguitos de la cuadra ya mis
hermanos carlos sainz
entonces la señora ya conocen mi primer
apodo
del bullying cago cain agréguenle que
usaba gafas gafas o ciego bis cornet o
cuatro ojos y agréguele por el apellido
pollo pollito gallinas o kikirikí o sea
que era un triple bullying pero casi que
no aprendo a hablar y a mi madre una
amiga le dijo hay que tener fe vaya
donde el padre y que le regale vino de
consagrar y me dieron todo el vino de
consagrar que ustedes quieran que por
eso termine de sacerdote de tanto vino
de consagrar
ahora iniciando esta charla del tedh
quiero presentarles al personaje más
importante que no soy yo puede un ser
humano amigas y amigos de aquí de
colombia o del extranjero por un ser
humano totalmente paralizado 10 años
moviendo solamente sus ojos
es años ni siquiera este pequeño dedo
puede ser una persona feliz
puede ser una persona que ayuda sin
moverse puede ser una persona que está
en paz
absolutamente doy gracias al universo de
haber estado varias veces junto a elsa
osorio a que le diagnostican la misma
enfermedad stephen hawking parálisis por
ela esclerosis lateral amiotrófica y los
últimos 10 años quieta en su cama
y van a ver los valores de esta mujer en
su camino espiritual
me encuentro con carolina la que vende
rosado esta linda mujer claudia la otra
enfermeras con amor humanas que pone el
corazón en lo que hacen y me dicen ella
lo escucha
ella piensa pero ya no puede ni hablar
ni digerir por eso como usted ve allá
arriba se alcanza a ver una parte que es
ese único alimento 10 años ella
solamente va a mover los ojos y a través
de estas letras que le ponemos al frente
va a comunicarse con usted pero yo dije
listo le hable a ella me dijo carolina
la de rosado ella le quiere hablar cómo
se comunicaban ya de manera perfecta
casi telepática se lo puso al frente y
ella comienza a ver si poner los ojos
arriba los grupos de arriba la mitad o
los de abajo luego ya escogió los de
arriba ahora si pone los ojos en el
centro a la derecha oa la izquierda en
este caso escogió a bs de luego letra
por letra parpadeo ya tenemos la primera
letra
y así conversamos un rato y su única
pregunta porque dios me mandó esto
muy común en la fe a veces equivocada
sin criticar le expliqué que ellos no
manda nada que son pruebas que son
aprendizajes de los seres humanos en
este plano le expliqué que hay un plan
que un alma atrás antes de venir aunque
algunas personas puede que les cueste
eso y haya escuchado y escuchada y de
pronto dice carolina le quiere contestar
nunca había pensado eso
yo puede haber escogido esto lo vivo
bien lo acepto no tengo problemas la
gente viene y se va feliz la gente dice
que le cambió la vida me traen personas
deprimidas me traen personas amputadas
me traen personas que están mal y todos
se van y dicen ya lo acepto no me quejo
y entonces una persona siente un camino
espiritual inmóvil en la cama pero este
móvil solamente su cuerpo su mente está
positiva sus emociones son hermosas su
en su consciencia es total y su espíritu
está espectacular y eso lo que yo quiero
compartirles ustedes y va a pedirles que
ojalá que y donde se encuentren
pongan la mano que quieran al frente y
vamos a grabar esto en el cerebro porque
cuando uno escucha aprende unas cosas
pero cuando participa graba más se
aprende más haciendo que escuchando si
lo quieres hacer vamos a enumerar para
que se graben nuestra mente y nos
acompañen nuestro caminar en lo que
queramos que somos la suma de cinco
realidades y los quiero escuchar con ese
ánimo que hay aquí en mi tierra él me
decía no en cualquier parte del mundo
digamos soy un espíritu
el espíritu maravilloso y llámalo al mar
llámalo como quieras esa energía que te
mueve para estar bien con una mente
ojalá esté siempre positiva te lleva a
soñar con imposibles a no rendirte a
lograr lo que quieras esa mente y ese
espíritu crean una emoción
emoción lo que hizo que ustedes viven
viven cuando aman cuando lloran cuando
están tristes son emociones emoción te
mueve conciencia
hoy en coincidencia el que vio en el que
maté al que roba el corrupto no es un
ser malo está en in con ciencia y el
cuerpo si esta mano tuya pongamos que se
paralizó el dedo pulgar como queda tu
mano muy inservible pongamos que el
meñique también está mal pues ahora mira
digamos digamos a ver gracias para que
se desgrave digan soy un espíritu con
una mente emociones conciencia y cuerpo
vamos en esta charla básicamente no va a
centrar en la parte del espíritu que es
aquel que cuando lo tienes descuidado no
nutrido no vigorizado está enclenque o
como decía el gran literato ruso gogol
reflejando todas las cosas que pasaban
antes en rusia- lo llamaba almas muertas
o como lo decía el gran poeta persa
musulmán espectacular místico la
religión musulmana y unas maravillas de
espiritualidad que llaman los sufíes y
decía rumí por allá en el siglo 13 la
mayoría de las almas están dormidas te
estás quemando un laberinto perdido pero
puede salir de allí y escoger dos
círculos en la vida yo cualquiera es
cuál es el círculo de aceptar lo que
vives acepto mi parálisis acepta mi
problema de comunicación
acepto el tráfico de la ciudad hace toda
la realidad o peleo con ella
batalló con ella es un círculo de total
desgaste y hay un ref hay un proverbio
de la india
tuve la fortuna de estudiar con 40
personas de la india tres años en roma
gracias cuanto aprendí y eso me lo
enseñaron a más resistencia mientras más
pelees con lo que quieras pecador qué
frío qué lluvia mi suegra mi novia mi
mamá el tráfico el alcalde más vas a
sufrir a más resistencia más sufrimiento
cuando se acepta no se puede sufrir por
eso hablamos de lo espiritual porque
miren lo que estuve en los futurólogos
que hay unas corrientes que buena al
mundo ese movimiento y hablaron de 10
hace unos años y todas se están
cumpliendo no se avance la tecnología de
la nanotecnología de la biotecnología el
cambio climático que lo que estamos
sufriendo pero al mismo tiempo
despertando todo ese movimiento con
conciencia de ecología que es
maravilloso y muy curioso el cuarto la
búsqueda espiritual
millares de personas que ustedes conocen
este mismo ya lo están haciendo no voy a
ningún templo pero medito oro a gota y
si practico chi kung hago rey que
escucho música relajante otros voy a mi
iglesia cristiana porque el culto es
espectacular voy a esa misa porque me
encanta el padre me llega judío budista
eso es secundario pero hay un gran
despertar espiritual de eso vengo a
hablarles ya darles unas lucecitas al
respecto y ese es esto que está en que
tiene relación con el despertar
espiritual que es lo que vemos en este
auditorio muchos hombres felicitaciones
pero más mujeres que hombres la mujer es
la que lidera el cambio espiritual del
ser humano y eso es bien importante
ustedes dirán pues está hablando del
sendero del espíritu
como se sabe que la persona es
espiritual
hay siete lucecitas que se prenden
cuando tú avanzas por ese camino en un
credo o sin él la primera es el amor
obvio de la vida la use de confucio
todos los maestros espirituales de
cualquier cultura de cualquier religión
sino que cuando hablamos del amor
palabra tan usada
es tan menospreciado tan prostituida el
labio te amo baby te amo te amo tan
fácil de decir te amo pero otra cosa es
practicarlo
se confunde el amor con la atracción
sexual y forma parte del amor se
confunde el amor con la necesidad pero
donde hay necesidad no hay amor se
confunde el amor con el deseo
pero es más que el deseo
y que hablamos cuando hablamos de amor
voy a recomendarles con cariño porque a
mí me ha ayudado en mi camino y le ayuda
a muchas parejitas que he podido guiar a
los que están aquí de novios en otra
parte hay un libro gratis en internet es
el mejor manual para amar por lo menos
en relación de pareja de un plan
psicoanalista un sabio una eminencia y
es un folleto pequeño pero si lo
aprendes y lo asimilas dirás cuántas
lágrimas medito cuántos completos
estéril es el arte de amar
apréndete no sólo eso que te llene de
esta conferencia
yo doy gracias de estar aquí de que en
muchos países alguien busque en internet
el arte de amar del gran psicoanalista
eric fromm no tienes que aprenderte el
escritor con el arte llamar gratis en
internet que vas a encontrar allí algo
extraño muy raro
qué escritor comienza su libro en este
prólogo
si este libro está en tus manos y tú
quieres que yo te voy a decir acá que
amar es fácil suéltalo dejarlo de lado
porque te va a ser exactamente todo lo
contrario que amar es un arte y todo
arte pide dedicación entrega compromiso
ganas por eso los invito a que hagan eso
desea de ese tipo de amor es el que
estamos hablando aquí ya es amor a la
pareja amor al hijo amor al amigo amor a
la naturaleza
espero que muchos de ustedes cuando
entraron a esta universidad eafit de
medellín hayan tenido ojos para ver las
horquillas apenas 20 metros después de
entrar pero hacer andamos en automático
con piloto automático y no contemplamos
eso pero por lo menos cuando salgan
aunque esté un poco oscuro miren las
rosas se están saliendo aquí a la
derecha ve qué pasa y no les veo o si
caminan un poco hacia adelante van a ver
una selva maravillosa no se los digo por
darme las sino porque los invito como no
lo puedo hacer yo despacio a desarrollar
esa sensibilidad de amor a la belleza de
la creación yo cuento este término mando
me a mí mismo amor a los dios y a los
demás eso es básicamente el amor pero se
quedan ustedes con esa inquietud de leer
ese libro yo me doy por bien servido y
doy gracias de estar acá personas que
van a empezar a ser artistas en el amor
así como fernando botero en colombia o
miguelángel hace años en italia o
velázquez en españa
chagall en rusia los grandes pintores
nos dejaron a obras maestras qué
maravilla que tu relación de pareja y tu
relación con los demás sea una obra
maestra las personas espirituales
también están en un estado de conciencia
voy a compartirles muy sencillamente
para mí lo que es conciencia voy a
agacharme aquí porque la mejor manera
explicárselos con las palabras de un
guía espiritual para mí de la india
llamado chris da morte vista multi se
sentaba en el suelo
y le decía a las personas conciencia
estar alerta
y así es cómo vives cómo te relacionas
alerta atención plena en inglés llama
mindfulness la atención está presente
aquí y ahora y ponía este ejemplo qué
pasa imagina que tú lo estás haciendo ya
que al frente de mí estaba en la india a
tres metros estaba una cobra venenosa
así
mirándome sacando la lengua estás
pensando en el último capítulo de la
telenovela
cómo está el dólar
estás atento totalmente alerta con la
cobra cuando tú haces eso en la vida y
sacas aunque sea cinco o diez minutos en
la noche mejor en la mañana
que estoy haciendo
así se comporta un buen marido
estoy tratando bien a mis empleados
si sigo haciendo esto para dónde voy
estás tomando conciencia alégrate llena
te de euforia porque ese es el secreto
para que tu vida esté llena de paz de
luz y de amor
aunque haya algunos conflictos
pitágoras nacido en una isla griega
llamada samos practicaba eso hace muchos
siglos con
personas
les hacían estas tres preguntas donde
estoy yo que hice hoy de positivo que se
de negativo
que deje de hacer esas personas también
tienen desapego no se aferran a nada ni
a las posiciones de las personas sirven
con amor y su fe es fuerte firme
impresionante e irradian paz interior
sin darse cuenta eso es lo que yo deseo
para ti que cultivando estos valores tu
vida se ilumine y logres inspirar e
iluminar a los demás y al hacerlo vas a
captar lo siguiente que lo fácil lo hace
cualquiera lo difícil lo hacen las
personas optimistas y lo excelente lo
maravilloso lo logran los seres
apasionados que casi siempre son
espirituales muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]